[Musique]
élégante familière et étrange à la fois
cette fleur primitive et d'ancêtres
communs de toutes les fleurs connue elle
était sans doute petit moins d'un
centimètre de diamètre
alors que les continents se détacher
encore les uns des autres au jurassique
l or et éclos à l'ombre des dinosaures
quelque part sur un arbuste ou un
buisson le portrait robot de cette fleur
éphémère et la somme du travail de la
trentaine de scientifiques du projet
i-flow les fossiles de fleurs sont rares
les plus anciens ont été trouvés en
espagne il remonte à 130 millions
d'années ce qui est récent car les
plantes à fleurs très cabaret
possiblement une centaine de millions
d'années auparavant
c'est dire qu'on ne connaît rien ou
presque de leurs origines pourtant c'est
un des mystères les plus importants qu'à
biologie évolutive
[Musique]
pour faire le portrait de ces fleurs
ancestrales les chercheurs ont comme
seul indice les fleurs moderne
ils se sont basés sur 800 fleurs
représentant la diversité moderne
c'est comme s'ils devaient deviner
l'apparence d'un mile en observant sa
descendance toutes les fleurs font
partie d'une même grande famille et
décennies des analyses génétiques
avaient permis de retracer leurs arbres
phylogénétiques à l'arbre généalogique
en quelque sorte et de remonter jusqu'à
un ancêtre commun
lafleur ancestrales ils ont ensuite
retracé l'évolution de leurs
caractéristiques morphologiques penser
par exemple que ces fleurs si en jaune
sont bisexuels
elle porte des organes mâles et femelles
celle ci en bleu sont unis sexuée
l'arbre permet de déduire que la
première fleur était probablement
bisexuelle
[Musique]
ils ont fait de même pour une vingtaine
d'autres traits comme le nombre et la
position des pétales des six pales des
étamines et des pistils en remontant
ainsi le temps ils ont schématisé
l'apparence des ancêtres des principaux
grands groupes de fleurs retraçant des
étapes clés de leur évolution jusqu'à
l'origine la fleur qui descendent toutes
les fleurs connus s'était pales sont
regroupés par trois
comme chez la tulipe mais avec au moins
quatre cycles comme celle berbérie elle
présente des cycles de trois et amine
comme celle à fleurs d'avocats sa
symétrie et radial comme la rose l'été
pâle et des étamines sont libres comme
si le coquelicot
il y a encore bien sûr des incertitudes
sur leur apparence pour plusieurs
demeureront à jamais avant l'arrivée des
fleurs la végétation était dominée par
les conifères des sica dalle et les
fougères dans les méthodes de
reproduction était plutôt rudimentaire
des sports et des graines porté par
l'eau et le vent les premières plantes à
fleurs des angiospermes ont été une
révolution du monde végétal
elles ont habillées lancement ce de
pétales coloré de nectar et de fruits
sucrés pour attirer les pollinisateurs
les frugivores pour la première fois les
plantes ont mis les animaux au service
de leur reproduction
cette invention a permis aux anges et au
sperme de conquérir la planète avec un
succès remarquable
à présent neuf plaintes sur 10 sont à
fleur avec plus de 300 mille espèces
connues elles fournissent aux humains
nourriture et matières premières et
surtout beauté et poésie
[Musique]